[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
remembering legend kobe bryant his
daughter and seven others killed in a
helicopter crash
one year ago at least nine lawsuits and
35 attorneys later
we look into the legal battles now
ongoing this debris field is telling me
that helicopter hit it at a high speed
prosecutors say parkland school shooter
nicolas cruz
etched swastikas into his boots and on
the apparent murder weapon what should
this evidence be shown to a jury
attorneys for the so-called doomsday
call mom say they can't speak to her in
private should laurie valodebel be given
a cell phone in jail
a judge approves a 17 million dollar
settlement for victims of harvey
weinstein
the convicted former movie producer must
now pay up he's not a sitting duck
he's not an easy target long prime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
one year ago the world was shocked when
news broke that kobe bryant his daughter
gianna
and seven others were killed in a
helicopter crash law and crimes anjanet
levy shows us where the investigation
stands
and what's coming next it's hard to
believe that it's been
exactly one year since kobe bryant his
daughter gianna
and seven other people were killed in
that helicopter crash
as the families mourn there are a number
of lawsuits pending in the courts
bryant's wife vanessa and families of
the other victims are suing the company
that operated the helicopter
there's definitely some reliability this
is not an act of god this is
not an act of nature this is what
appears to be pilot error
that was aviation expert andrew maloney
on law and crime the day after the crash
last year
pilot era zobian was trying to fly out
of the clouds when the swarovski
s-76b helicopter crashed into a mountain
last year
other lawsuits stemming from the crash
the helicopter company is suing two air
traffic controllers
and vanessa bryant is suing los angeles
county and its sheriff's department
and oddly enough vanessa bryant faces a
lawsuit from her own mother
but as far as the lawsuit over the crash
goes
several factors are relevant including
the fog that morning
this time lapse video shows the
conditions you can see
just how thick that fog was before it
cleared
it looks like weather played a role here
i think
the fog the the conditions of the
visibility conditions were very poor
the lapd had grounded its fleet now they
may have a different mission profile
than the helicopter that mr bryant was
flying on but
clearly there was a weather issue the
ntsb
is expected to release the results of
its crash report on february 9
and we will bring those results to you
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
thanks angeanette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike corebonix
and terry austin
terry talk to us about the last year for
the bryant family their life
the litigation and his legacy you know
brian this has been a very difficult
year for the family for the obvious
reasons that they lost their father
they lost a loving father and a loving
daughter so
it's very difficult for vanessa and i
think and the whole family the
difficulty has
only been compounded by these lawsuits
and the very first lawsuit was actually
filed by
vanessa and i think she obviously had a
duty to file a wrongful death action
against the company who operated
the helicopter they were definitely
negligent maybe
weather had something to do with it but
there was definitely negligence
and she will lose income for her family
so i think she made the right move when
she filed this lawsuit i just hope that
it settles at the end
of the day so they don't spend so much
money
on litigation now mike five lawsuits
involve the fatal crash
the probable cause for that crash is
supposed to be released
february 9th as angenette told us what
do you think we should be focusing on
when it does come out well this is going
to be
a case that's going to be determined by
experts the expert testimony as to what
exactly went wrong with the
with the flight what was the causation
that's the main issue of this case
this will be a case that will ultimately
be a battle of the experts
if it ever gets to trial all right now
terry three of the cases are about the
invasion of privacy when the sheriff's
department shared photos of the crash
what are the brian's chances of success
there
oh i think she has a very good chance of
succeeding there you know it's like
adding
insult to injury obviously she lost her
husband
she lost her daughter and then for these
authorities to take
pictures and to share those pictures the
lawsuit is
an invasion of privacy and it just has
to show
that there was public disclosure of a
private piece of information
and so i do hope that she wins there and
it actually prompted
a law in california for it to be a
misdemeanor for
first responders to take and publicize
pictures like that
yeah now the hope is the fact that that
law occurred
might be giving them some sort of wiggle
room to win those
invasion of privacy cases and of course
you got the wrongful
wrongful death suit sorry coming up
we'll get more information on february
9th thank you both
new england patriots owner robert kraft
has scored what looks to be his final
legal victory in an alleged sex crimes
case
a federal judge in florida has ordered
video that reportedly shows craft naked
in a massage parlor
paying for sex be destroyed a judge
ruled the sneak and peak warrant the
jupiter police
department secured for the sting
operation violated patrons right to
privacy
prosecutors were then forced to throw
out the misdemeanor solicitation charge
against craft craft defense won their
motion to keep the video of their client
from ever being public
new video has been released in the
arrest of singer trey songz
at the afc championship football game
kansas city police posted a video of the
altercation
they claim shows a singer whose name is
tremaine aldon neverson
punching an officer and putting them in
a headlock kansas city police say
fans complained about a man not wearing
a mask and the man then refused to leave
when asked by private security and
officers that's when trey songz
allegedly attacked the officer
he's since been released from jail
charges are pending
one of the winners of the foo network
show worst cooks in america
has been arrested for the murder of a
three-year-old girl ariel robinson
along with her husband jerry are accused
of beating their adopted daughter to
death police in south carolina say the
couple inflicted
a series of blunt force injuries to the
child who was adopted from the state's
foster system
the food network has pulled season 20 of
the show ariel robinson was named the
winner last august
if convicted the robinsons face up to 20
years in prison
still ahead on law and crime daily the
shocking evidence the state wants to use
against the accused parkland school
shooter and later
the latest motion filed in the doomsday
cult duo case we break down the request
from lori valo dabel's attorney
[Music]
prosecutors in a parkland school
shooting case are seeking to introduce
at trial
photos of hand-etched swastikas in the
suspect's gun and boots
nicholas cruz faces 17 counts of murder
and 17 counts of attempted murder for
the valentine's day
2018 massacre cruz is accused of taking
an ar-15 firearm
to go on a six-minute long shooting
rampage at marjory stoneman douglas high
school
investigators say the shooter abandoned
the gun in a stairwell
the weapon seen here in photos submitted
by the state
appears to have a nazi swastika symbol
etched into both sides of the magazine
crews confessed to the killing in a
police interrogation how long have you
had that gun
a year or two a year or two did you buy
it yourself
where'd you buy it at
i mean you're 19 right so
did you buy it from a gun store or you
buy it from a friend
a gun store also submitted is this photo
of cruz's boot with a swastika etched
into it
records show cruz was wearing the boot
when he was arrested
in their motion prosecutors say they
want the jury to see these photos to
prove identity and connect him to the
scene of the crime
the state has no intention of arguing
the racist nature of the symbol or that
the defendant is a racist
five of the 17 victims were jewish
defense attorneys for nicholas cruz are
asking for two weeks to review the
motion
before responding the state filed
i believe it was on friday emotion in
lemonade and we would ask
for some time to respond to that in
writing please
i'm going to give the office of the
public defender two weeks to respond to
the state's motion and lemonade so that
will leave us
at
february 8th it's flying with the state
you're hungry
that's fine judge and that um includes
the other case correct
yes 8 45 on february 16th i'll see you
all then thank you
no trial date has been set for cruz's
case prosecutors say they'll seek the
death penalty if cruz is convicted
back for analysis as defense attorney
mike corbonitz and co-host terry austin
terry it doesn't make sense to me the
grounds of the prosecutors pushing this
to say that the swastika and the gun and
boot are going to be used to prove
identity
can you make heads or tails of that for
us you know brian i think it does
actually make sense i mean we know
identification is not
an issue really at this point there's a
video there witnesses
but it doesn't hurt to corroborate the
evidence and if there's
an identification mark it just happens
to be a swastika
on both the boot and the gun why not tie
that together it sort of corroborates
what the video says and what the other
witnesses might be saying
and it makes it clear that this is the
actual
individual who had that gun who marched
in there
and on you know february 14th shot all
of these innocent people so i think it
makes sense
mike i i gotta disagree i'm sorry terry
i don't see how it does identity
mike the second i saw the swastika i
thought he's anti-semitic
the second i realized the community he
was in he hates jewish people
you're not gonna be able to unring that
bell once you show that swastika
is that not the point of why you don't
do this in court
yeah well brian i am very disappointed
in the prosecutor's
approach to this because they should be
forthright and forthcoming with the
court to avoid any appeals
they are doing that not for
identification it's not an issue
it's not an issue in the case although
just because you may stipulate that
doesn't mean that the state is
prohibited
from putting forth more than more
evidence their burdens beyond the
reasonable doubt
if they want to add more evidence
they're more than welcome to
i think it's dangerous when they say
they're only using it
to corroborate because i think an
appellate court would say no you're not
you're looking at it to show he was
anti-semitic and this is what occurred
they should really watch and be careful
and be very articulate on the
evidential reasons they're trying to use
this otherwise they should leave it
alone
yeah my fear is that if they don't do it
properly
this is going to get appealed and come
back and forth and back and forth
and no one not the victims not anyone
watching wants that
but if you're going to call them
anti-semitic do it
and prove it and i think they have all
the evidence there thank you both for
joining in on that
conversation uh coming up on lawn crime
daily the payout the victims of the
harvey weinstein should finally see
plus the so-called doomsday caught mom's
unusual request for jail
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
a defense attorney for the so-called
doomsday cult mom wants to be able to
talk to his client
on a private cell phone while she awaits
trial
terry austin has the latest on what's
behind this jailhouse request
brian attorney mark means says covet 19
restrictions prevent him from speaking
freely
with lori vallo in jail so he wants to
give her
a cell phone lori vallo and her husband
chad dabel are charged with concealing
and destroying evidence
while valo's children were reported
missing authorities discovered the
bodies of j.j
and tyler ryan buried in a shallow grave
and dabell's property
means submitted these photos from his
meetings with valo
into evidence he claims he's unable to
communicate privately with her
the sheriff's office confirmed two of
their phone calls last march
were accidentally recorded and later
deleted
he's also requesting cameras in their
meeting room be
turned off the next hearing for valo's
case is scheduled
for march 22nd forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan says
we're still waiting for investigators to
release the children's
cause of death you know when are they
going to pull the trigger on this thing
and actually charge them with a homicide
we have these conspiracy charges and
this sort of thing and that's all fine
and good
but you know that they don't have a lot
of weight when you start to talk about
uh
you know the abuse of a corpse or what
however they're framing this
legally but you know what we're really
waiting on
is you know these charges relatives
specifically relative to these deaths
and we found out that this is
something that is on the horizon it it
just has to be at this point
i think this goes back to this idea of
her meeting with her attorney
this is highly complex and this requires
regardless of how you feel about laurie
davil if you're planning a defense
this requires a very detailed succinct
uh creation of a timeline uh just so
that the
defense has a way to understand this so
that's very important that they have
the ability to meet here for legal
analysis is mike corebonix and terry
austin mike
as strangers that may sound this request
by the defense not being able to speak
privately with your client means you
don't really have attorney
client privilege uh in those
conversations is that really the issue
at heart here
absolutely um i've actually had uh brian
have had these issues
it's it's horrible the situation we're
in
with kovid however those telephone lines
are usually recorded
now they said they taped two
accidentally that doesn't give the
privilege away and whether or not they
could be used
you're somebody has access to intimate
conversations between the attorney
and his client suppose in this instance
they're talking about a plea deal what
would be accepted
and even though that's not used at court
if that gets back to the prosecution
they know where their strengths and
weaknesses are negotiating it's totally
unfair
i don't think it's an unreasonable
request in these in this day
and age with a pandemic and he should be
able to give a dedicated phone
only to his number that she can't make
outgoing calls to and he has to arrange
i don't see anything wrong with it
and i think it's going to be the wave of
the future now tara what do you think is
val having her own private cell phone i
don't know if it's going to be a brick
phone flip phone
iphone 12 i don't know is that the
answer here though
you know i actually agree 100 with
michael here there's no
question that covet 19 has caused a lot
of problems and
obviously under the sixth amendment you
have a right to counsel
which means you should have these
privileged conversations you should have
privacy
no one should be recording it whether
it's an accident or not
and so i do think that because of the
pandemic
across the country we're going to have
to figure out solutions
where attorneys can talk to their
clients and have
some reasonable expectation of privacy
so maybe you give her a flip phone
that only calls to the attorney and has
one number but we need to do something
to solve this really serious issue
yeah i think it's probably one of those
phones you can only call one person like
the ones you give to your like 14 year
old kid or something like that
thank you both when we come back the
lawsuit years in the making now approved
for victims of harvey weinstein the 17
million dollar payout
next
a judge has approved the settlement
payout for victims of convicted sex
offender harvey
weinstein as long crimes jesse webber
tells us it's going to be split amongst
different parties
the alleged victims of disgraced former
producer harvey weinstein can now expect
to be
paid a u.s bankruptcy judge has
officially approved a 35.2
million dollar settlement for the
liquidation of the weinstein company
as part of this deal over 17 million
dollars has been set aside to pay out
and resolve
claims of sexual misconduct now while
some women have expressed their
opposition
over 40 accusers have agreed to this
plan after i was raped by weinstein in
2005 i was confused
why didn't i scream why didn't i fight i
thought i was stronger and i hated
myself for being
weak that self-hate turned into shame
and guilt
shame that i never should have felt and
guilt that was not mine to own
i didn't know that at the time and i
didn't realize it for 12 more years
harvey weinstein stole a part of my
self-worth treating me like i was
nothing and i became fearful and
mistrustful
not only of others but of myself these
feelings were unbearable to live with
and i pushed back the fear
shame and guilt to move on with my life
because that's how most of us survive
i was okay or so i thought until i read
about the brave women speaking out with
their stories just like mine
i hope that the sentence sends a clear
message that times have changed and that
more women need to speak out for
themselves and that men
and women need to speak out for each
other we need to show self love and
empathy to overcome
centuries of illogical thinking that has
normalized the sexual mistreatment of
women
this is hopefully just the beginning and
the conversation must continue
paul zumbro an attorney for the
weinstein company says that his team
is pleased with the ruling especially
since quote
there is now a mechanism that allows
victims to receive compensation
without having to endure the hardships
and uncertainties of litigation
now while the agreement also provides
for legal expenses no funds are going to
be allocated to pay for weinstein's own
legal bills if you're going to bring a
claim listen he's not a sitting duck
he's not an easy target he's going to
defend these claims whether they be
these civil claims or
the criminal claims in in los angeles
he's not giving up he's vested in his
defense both
criminal and civil and he's going to
defend himself against these allegations
and as for weinstein himself while he's
currently serving a 23-year prison
sentence in new york for sex crimes
and is still awaiting trial in la on
other sexual assault charges
i'm jesse weber for long crime
thanks jesse back one last time for
analysis is mike corbonix and
terry austin mike 17 million sounds like
a lot until it's split between
about 50 victims those with the most
serious claims
seem to be getting about 500 000 how
does that sit with you
well i there's a practical point of this
is
obviously weinstein has a lot of money
there were
debts that were owed the money
supposedly went away i'd like to see a
better
following of the money but what you have
in your hand is better than what you may
miss out by time
trial comes when there may be no money
left it doesn't seem to compensate but
it seems to
to be the best situation they have
exactly not terry
approximately 40 women voted four and
eight against
this settlement according to some of
their lawyers it limits their ability to
seek
other remedies is this a win or
something just short of that
you know brian i think it's a win but
it's a lopsided win it provides
i think too much money for weinstein's
company and
for the lawyers and not enough money as
far as the victims are concerned and
that really should be our number one
concern i mean
the amount was actually reduced early on
they said it was going to be
24 million for the victims and now
they've
reduced it to the 17 million so i don't
think it's enough for the victims even
if the serious crimes
have a higher amount but the good news
and this is what mike said and i agree
with
him wholeheartedly the good news is that
it'll be resolved and that they won't
have to spend a lot of money on
litigation because as we all know
attorneys fees
really do eat up the sums that could be
available for these victims
well maybe mike korobonnik's attorney's
fees i'm still working for free but
absolutely terry thank you both for
joining us
and you know what i really like we're
coming at this because i think the most
important thing
that i will agree with you terry is the
finality for those victims and we can
call them victims now especially because
he's convicted
because having to relive this uh not
only through just life
the criminal case but then doing it
again in a civil case no person should
have to do that
and i think even though the number isn't
enough i think it does fall just short
of justice
it's done thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you